des murs de suie noire d'où s'échappent
encore des fumées voilà à quoi ressemble
les dix mille mètres carrés de la
fourrière municipale et des parking
adjacent à l'intérieur plus de 120
véhicules ont été détruits par les
flammes
une centaine d'autres endommagées ce
matin quelques habitants venaient aux
nouvelles comme ce monsieur qui avait
mis sa voiture à l'abri
le jour du réveillon je dis je la mets
tant de sécurité ti comme je savais que
ça va être la mieux devrions pas que ça
qui va nous la caté est en fin de
contrat matin au pénal quand je ne
pourrai récupérer mauvais que dans 9h15
9h20 on m'a dit non monsieur pourrait
pas rentrer vos toitures et l'emploi dur
constat pour les habitants de planoise
qui perdent aussi un supermarché et une
galerie commerciale située au dessus des
parkings mais pour la châtre goûtant
maintenant qu'il faut toutes les
histoires qu'ils enlèvent qui fasse le
bilan est si c'est quoi il ya une
évaluation comme ça un peu large qui
consiste à dire que peut-être pendant
quatre mois ce bâtiment sera pas
accessible
donc est ce qu'on trouvera une autre
solution pour implanter le commerce dans
planoise parce que c'est fondamental
enfin que penser de ces émanations de
fumées qui ont envahi le quartier un
brouillard épais difficile à supporter
qui a terriblement compliqué la tâche
des pompiers
vingt-quatre heures après beaucoup
d'habitants s'interroge tient
impressionnant c'est très impressionnant
oui ça fait peur quand même
j'attaque couché qu'il ya là beaucoup
d'amiante donc comment la misha plus
l'odeur de pneus chat bâtiment qu'est
venu et donc vous n'êtes pas venir
capable en devenant j'avais mal au crâne
et puis je trouve sa masse est né du
coup j'ai pas dans la narration est ce
que ça sentait trop fort oui les
pompiers qui ont réalisé des contrôles
n'ont pas trouvé de produits cyanure et
les plus dangereux pour l'homme sa 57
des grosses valeurs mais
ses pensées pas significatif -
rassurante
l' agence régionale de santé a émis dès
ce matin des recommandations éviter tout
contact avec les suit nettoyer les
fenêtres seulement à l'eau ne pas
utiliser de nettoyeur haute pression
pour ne pas mettre en suspension
les particules de suie il faudra du
temps pour dresser un bilan complet de
cet incendie exceptionnel par son
ampleur
résultat d'un geste criminel lié au
banditisme